une voiture c'est toujours le domaine un
peu je suis dans un bagne rien m'arriver
j'ai un art au pouvoir la testostérone
monte
j'ai toujours eu des voitures puissantes
j'ai une ferrari ou corps étranger qui
va dans une porsche décapotable
évidemment il ya beaucoup d'hommes 18
ans et on sent super héros juste vitesse
ou si c'est les autres qui font si
souvent des femmes et la répression la
répression quand est-ce qu'elle va
s'arrêter je descends lui dit très
souvent sans trembler c'est pas possible
que je continue à rouler à 180 ou 200 je
respecte tout sauf la vitesse
tout le monde cherche au mur sont au
point de non retour donc à vous insérer
votre mur cua edgard de pas vous prendre
par la figure
c'est un bilan de guerre finalement ne
jamais trouver d'autres méthodes que le
collier et ça ils n'acceptent pas les
gens devraient marathon strain à 50 moi
j'ai l'impression je recule et recule à
50 n'est tout de même dans la débilité
mentale
est ce que c'est cette humanité merde
alors est-ce que vous téléphonez n'était
pas mise au point de m
moi je dis pas que j'ai tellement plus
rageur comme agen n'était jamais un
petit peu chaud
on m'a rendu mon permis le 10 octobre
2010 à 10 heures au nez à 10h20 où il
fait beau les surcoûts